I'm pleased to introduce Dr Anna [inaudible].
She's a sociologist,
entrepreneur,
innovation consultant and writer.
Her research focuses on visual and virtual self presentation,
technology in human intersects,
dating and interpersonal relationships in happiness and wellbeing.
She's here today to talk about her book startup,
Your Life Hustle in hack your way to happiness.
Please join me in giving a warm welcome to Dr Akbari.
Hi,
welcome.
Thank you for taking time out of your day today.
It's going to tell you some different stories today and first I want to zap us
back to the year 2008 many of you probably remember that year I was about to
celebrate a major birthday.
I was living in New York City.
I was broke,
I was single and I lived in an old walkup tenement building in Hell's kitchen.
But despite all of that,
I was elated because I also had just finished my dissertation and my phd.
So for me that was this huge milestone that I had been working toward and it was
this thing that was going to offer all kinds of opportunity and ultimately
happiness.
Wow.
Well,
given that it was 2008 within a few months,
everything came crashing down in every sector was affected from Wall Street to
academia.
And I was really,
my life felt really out of control.
And while the timing of this and the particular details of that story might be
different for each of us,
trying to make sense of chaos and trying to find happiness at times of chaos is
universal as,
I mean,
all of us have to deal with at different points in our lives.
Too often,
you know,
we invest so much in those big milestones,
no matter what's happening in the rest of the world.
When I finished that degree,
when I get that promotion,
I am going to be happy.
But really in reality,
life is what happens in between those big moments.
And so in startup your life and my new book,
I look to Silicon Valley and the methodologies and principles that guide it to
use that as a springboard for tools that you can use in your own life to be
happier and more successful no matter what point you're at in your career or
your personal development.
So why a startup approach,
um,
you know,
maybe aren't,
don't have to convince you guys have that,
but I think it's still is worth articulating.
You know,
when startups launch,
chances are they're going to fail.
Chances are not that they're going to have $1 billion exit that's more of a pipe
drain.
It's something that we hear about a lot in the news,
but it's not the reality for most everyone.
And you can't really plan.
You don't even know if you're gonna be around tomorrow.
So you have to find a way to be happy in the process.
Along the journey.
They iterate,
they experiment,
they fail,
they pivot.
And that joy in the process is something that a lot of us don't really allow
ourselves a lot of time and space to do.
So this is an approach about happiness today.
Not Happiness someday because it's really not the promotion,
it's not the marriage,
it's,
it's the small stuff.
It's the minutiae of your everyday life.
The choices that you make on an everyday basis.
What you're eating right now for lunch,
the culture you engage with the company,
you keep,
the way you present yourself at a meeting or a presentation,
it's the cumulative effect of all of those things that ultimately have the
biggest impact on these bigger milestones and so often we see a disconnect
between them.
I think it's small stuff doesn't matter.
So this is about how the small stuff really does matter and this is the approach
to living that I needed but couldn't find back in 2008
I want to quick get a sense of how do you guys feel about self help?
Do you read self help?
Are you into it?
Hate it.
You like it,
you read it,
okay,
well maybe,
maybe some of this resonates with you.
I struggle a lot with that genre.
It's something that I'm inclined toward.
I like self help in theory,
but I have a really hard time connecting with many of the self help books out
there for two main reasons.
One,
I find that a lot of self help books offer one single directive.
If you just think positively,
if you meditate,
if you dance spontaneously,
your life's going to be fantastic.
And of course all those things are terrific and all things I like to do,
but there's not a panacea for happiness or success or they're written by someone
that I just can't relate to in certainly could not relate to.
Back in 2008 someone who already has their career all figured out and is
thriving and has the perfect family and is financially stable and has their
dream home.
And so there's a disconnect.
You're forced to read between the lines and find where does my story fit into
this?
So while the bad news is there's no panacea,
the good news is you can start working on this stuff today and you don't need
bundles of cash or even to be a genius to be able to be happier and more
fulfilled starting right away.
Life is a business.
And I'm going to lay out a few of the key principles that I talk about in my
book that I think everyone can start applying to their large today.
And a few simple directives that will help you to integrate it.
So the first of the five is hustle.
This is one of my favorite words because it's really been reappropriated from
having some pretty negative connotations.
Um,
so I was born in Waterloo,
Iowa in a mid sized industrial,
a Midwestern town to a single mother and for political reasons and drama worthy
of a book onto itself.
I've never met my Iranian father and anyone who grew up with a single parent or
know someone who did knows it's hard.
It's really hard.
And My mother's family,
my grandfather was a truck driver and my grandmother raised five kids and worked
retail.
So there was no family money.
Uh,
but we did have government assistance and we lived in a very colorful apartment
complex on the east side of town where the characters were exactly what you'd
expect at a place that costs under a hundred dollars more to live there.
And we didn't have a car and rode the bus.
And luxury for us was sharing a plate of fries and a piece of chocolate pie
while we waited for the bus.
And those small little moments and those luxuries were also reminders of the
constant financial struggle.
But I wanted to be more than the circumstances that I was born into.
So I hustled and I studied and I rose through the ranks like I'm sure many of
you did as well.
And I eventually went on to go to some very expensive schools for many years.
And at the time I was really oblivious to the disparity between my financial
situation and the people that were around me.
And people assume that I was wealthy and when they found out that I wasn't,
they would say,
oh,
we're just lucky.
And I talk about this in my book,
and I don't know how you feel about that word,
but I hate it.
Anyone who's ever had their success dismissed as luck.
All.
It doesn't make me want to fight harder and be better.
And so that's what I tried to do.
I bootstrapped my life.
Now,
bootstrapping is something we hear quite often in the startup world and it's
something that a lot of startups have to do out of necessity,
where you basically do without money and you call on whatever resources you do
have to make the most of the situation.
But it's hard.
Bootstrapping is really difficult.
That breeds a survival mentality and it teaches you some really hard lessons
very fast whether you're ready for it or not,
but you don't have to be starting a company to realize the benefits of
bootstrapping readily.
It's something,
it's more about attitude being a hustler.
It's something that everyone can embrace because scrappiness,
not pedigree prevails in the long run.
And Hustling keeps you hungry.
And Hunger always beats complacency.
So does anyone know what the single biggest indicator is of longterm health and
happiness?
Any ideas?
Sorry?
Genes.
That is a factor for sure.
Yes.
Resilience is good.
Yeah.
Uh,
but something that would contribute to your health.
Okay.
There's a big one.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's it.
That's the big one.
So all of those that you mentioned are definitely part of it.
But social connections,
you know,
companionship.
Something we crave is the single biggest indicator of whether you're going to be
happy and healthy longterm.
So much so that if you are lacking in personal close ties,
it's the equivalent of smoking a pack of cigarettes a day or being obese.
So it's a pretty big,
it's a pretty big deal.
And you know,
partnerships,
they're hard.
So it's easy to say I'm going to do it by myself.
But you know,
business partners and spouses are very similar in a lot of ways.
There's even a honeymoon phase where you think that they're perfect and
everything's fantastic and then you know,
the blemishes start to rise to the surface and the daily tensions,
uh,
start to erode the social graces.
But successful partnerships,
whether it's in business or for pleasure,
are more similar than you might imagine.
And they are not about strength and strength or perfection and perfection.
Oftentimes it's the baggage that we bring to those and something we all have
plenty of that actually makes the relationship stronger and the other person
better because whatever it is that you're bringing to the table,
you're challenging that person in a new,
a diff in different way than they would be if they are with someone that's just
like them or if they didn't engage with you at all.
Uh,
Jeff Visa's,
one of your neighbors here,
uh,
when he was looking for a partner,
it is told that he actually created a flow chart of the women that he was
dating.
And he approached it like a business and he said that the biggest thing he was
looking for was someone who could get him out of a third world prison because
life is too short to be with someone that isn't resourceful.
And so I have to kind of agree.
Scrappiness,
your sexiness is great,
but scrappiness,
practicality and whole lot of humor goes a long way in both business and
pleasure.
But relationships are significant in our lives,
far beyond just romance or even business partnerships.
There was a time in my life when I used to say that I really wanted a,
uh,
a patron.
I wanted someone to,
a sponsor of sorts to,
to fund all of my creative pursuits.
And of course that doesn't exist.
And uh,
but I realized I sort of had a variation of that already.
So entrepreneurs will seek their money formally from investors.
Um,
but in our personal lives,
we don't usually have that opportunity.
So we have what I call life vcs and life feces are essentially the individuals
in our lives that console us.
They mentor us,
they make introductions,
they riff with us on ideas.
And these are,
it's important to note that a,
this is not networking as usual.
This is not something that's achieved by throwing a business card at someone or
just linking in with them and then disappearing.
This is about cultivating relationships,
both really close and also more peripherally over the course of a long time.
So that there's a constant feedback loop.
And one of the things that prevents that from happening is a phenomenon that has
really skyrocketed as of late,
which is ghosting.
Anyone been ghosted lately?
It used to be sort of this thing that would happen more in dating.
Does everyone know what goes teen is?
No.
Okay.
Yeah.
Go seeing is basically where you maybe have a date with someone or you have a
business meeting with someone,
something where you would at least think the person would respond to you.
It's not a cold call,
let's put it that way.
And then,
and then they never ever get back to you.
Um,
and this is happening more and more in the professional world as well.
You might even submit a proposal to someone and then suddenly you can't get them
to respond to you for months or maybe ever.
And what happens when we do varying degrees of ghosting is we cut out the
opportunity to nurture those relationships so that we can be mutual life vcs to
each other.
And remember,
you never know where the value in your network is going to land.
The person who introduces you to your life mate or that leads to the
introduction that gets you your dream job.
That might not come from your best friend.
That might not come from a formal mentor.
It might be someone that you have quietly been keeping in touch with and you
have this mutual respect and understanding about.
So remember that you're only as good as the company you keep and the work that
you put in to keeping that company around.
All right,
three
embrace failure.
We've all heard of the game.
Angry birds,
right?
One of the most downloaded games of all time.
But what you may not know about angry birds is the company that created it.
Rovio entertainment was not a smashing success before angry birds came on the
scene.
Does anyone,
in fact,
they were close to bankruptcy before angry birds came out.
Does anyone know how many failed or underwhelming games Rovio put out before
angry birds and when?
When?
I guess,
yeah,
25 or what?
Yeah,
so the second was closer.
51 game.
Angry birds was their 52nd try.
That's pretty phenomenal.
Most people don't have the patients fail formally 51 times before.
And it's not like angry birds was this overnight,
you know,
sort of Instagram.
It was,
it took a while to really build and to have to dominate in the way that it did.
So let's do think my life has been all successes.
So I think I've kind of already established that wasn't the case.
Um,
I've had quite a few of my own 51 failures days and when I first dipped my toe
and the entrepreneurial and startup world,
it was completely by accident.
I was at a friend's house party on a roof in New York,
and this was years ago.
And after sharing a bottle of wine,
I said,
I,
I wanted to start a new social networking platform.
Uh,
it was going to be like Friendster.
Remember Friendster low,
one of the really early social networking platforms only.
This one was going to isolate your dating network.
It was going to link you and visualize everyone you've dated and everyone
they've dated.
And so you'd see all your degrees of relationships based on your dating history.
Now this was a terrible idea.
That's why you've never heard of it before.
But a friend that was there thought that I was somewhat serious,
I guess,
or thought it was amusing idea,
pass it on to another friend and we ended up talking about it.
He was a software developer and we were able to isolate what wasn't so terrible
about it and that was tracking in person connections and relationships.
And so we started building something and raising money and all the investors
said the same thing.
They said,
sounds great,
really interesting.
Come back to us when you have some traction.
Well,
to get traction,
we decided maybe it'd be better if we pivoted to enterprise and we partnered
with a bunch of big players in that space.
We joined a tech incubator,
we did all these things we were supposed to do,
but the money never came.
The traction never happened.
We were,
we were shifting out of our skillsets and the partnerships were crumbling and it
just wasn't going to happen.
But this wasn't a parent for 18 months.
We bootstrapped for 18 months and then ultimately had this,
just say,
you know what?
This isn't working.
It's not going to happen.
So at the end of that I had no money,
no company,
and no idea what to do next.
And of course my family thought I was absolutely crazy.
And amid the wallowing,
which I did for about two weeks,
uh,
I had this epiphany when I had been pitching to investors.
Many of them said they would look at my bio and they would say,
yeah,
this is fine,
but you know,
I'm really interested in that other thing.
You do that intelligent image consulting.
What's that?
Why don't you,
why don't you do something with that?
And I dismissed it every single time I was so closed to it.
I thought it was just a side hobby.
And it wasn't until I fell on my face with the other project that I thought I
should be working on that finally it became clear to me that the thing that
actually had the most promise and the most legs was the thing that had been
standing in front of me the entire time.
But it's amazing how incapacitated would become when we limit and narrow our
outlets for success and our definition of,
of what we should or shouldn't be doing.
And so that moment was embarrassing and humbling and I was completely exhausted
and all I wanted to do was crawl in a hole or runaway to a surf camp and never
come back again.
But that wasn't,
that wasn't the reality that I chose.
It wasn't practical.
And you know,
in,
in Silicon Valley they say that if you aren't failing frequently,
you aren't risking enough.
And Henry Ford,
one of our great inventors said,
failure is an opportunity to begin again more intelligently.
And when you think about the individuals who we really revere as are our
innovators,
the Henry Ford's and the Thomas Edison's,
they failed more often than they succeeded.
And yet we think of them in relationship to their successes because they
persevered because they made something out of those failures.
Out of all the experiments that they do,
that and the resilience that they exhibited,
their 51 plus tries.
But most of us lose patients with cultivating success in that way.
And so we settle for mediocrity.
We settled the stuff that doesn't even really make us happy.
So how can we get past that?
Well,
we can remember that failure and success are not actually opposites there
compliments that,
that operate on the same spectrum.
So if we start to redefine failure,
then there's more,
there's more space for it.
And then when we do ultimately fail or not so derailed because we were expecting
it.
And also failure is where we grow from.
We don't grow from our triumphs.
I think about the thing about when you've done really well at something now
think about a time that you really fell on your face.
When did you learn the most?
You know,
what?
What changed your life the most?
It's,
it's usually the hard one,
but only if we take the time to self reflect,
to process,
to do the analysis and work through it and then fail up and make something out
of it.
So we can make space for failure by surfing fear because it's often the fear
that stands in our way of moving forward and taking these leaps.
So putting ourselves out there.
Okay.
Failure's good for pivots.
2015 blasting the head a few years now.
So 2008 I was wallowing in 2015 I was on the top of the world.
I,
it was a great,
it was a year of great personal change,
but at the beginning of it I felt so blessed with life's riches.
I was so happy and grateful for having finally,
after all that hard work,
creating stability in my life,
I was in a long term serious relationship.
The intent to marry,
I had professional opportunities that were just coming at me in ways I hadn't
anticipated and I was really physically healthy and vivacious.
Lice was good and then within a matter of months I broke off the relationship.
I moved very suddenly and I learned I had a really serious health condition that
demanded immediate attention.
And so the future,
the one that I had only just a few months ago thought was,
you know,
I'm not going to be perfect forever,
but I could just maybe take a breath for a while,
was no longer that,
that safety,
that security blanket was now devastatingly uncertain.
Okay.
If we go back to failure,
failure is really just change.
That's all it is.
And change is always present.
It's constant.
So the sooner we learn to flourish in change,
in transition,
the better off we'll be.
So what is transition?
What does it mean to be in transition?
William Bridges outlines three phases of transition and I find these to be
pretty accurate.
There's endings first one,
the endings,
then it's the neutral zone and then it's new.
So for me,
the end of my relationship is ending period.
Just like it is with any relationship.
And I'm sure you can relate to this,
it brings up feelings of nostalgia where you're not really sure if you're
missing the person or you're missing the idea of the person or the romanticized
notion of them are really just that familiarity.
And then once you get a little bit of distance,
you're left kind of shivering alone in the neutral zone.
That's where the emptiness really starts to settle and it's hard to move into
that phase.
And for anyone who's ever had a serious illness or anyone close to you has
experienced that you,
you understand the huge weight of medical uncertainty.
Our need for closure is so high at that point.
We just want to know,
we want to know what is happening,
even if it's bad,
we want that certainty,
but science,
even science and maybe especially science often can't give that to us and so
we're,
we're left just hovering without hard answers.
Then we ultimately get to the new beginning phase,
the pangs of heartbreak flipped to the side and new love interests come forward
and after difficult procedures and surgery and all sorts of medical drama,
you slip into a new phase of perpetual monitoring.
Not I'm healthy forever,
but perpetual monitoring,
which really is a constant reminder of both the fragility,
I think and the resilience of the human body and we can never effect,
we can never anticipate how the effect that these events will have on us.
For me.
I thought I was going to panic,
that I was going to have so much anxiety that I wasn't actually going to move
forward in my life,
and that was not the way I responded in this particular moment.
This strange wave of calm washed over me and maybe at times that have been
really difficult.
Some of you have felt that too,
where you surprise yourself and the way that you actually deal with trauma and
everyday was a new puzzle to solve.
It gave me a sense of purpose and I knew that those small victories,
just knowing what was supposed to come next was enough.
And so it's at those moments that we realize that we're in a state of permanent
transition,
that we can slip into what I call blissful uncertainty and just exist there
because that notion of stability is,
is false,
and that blissful uncertainty can actually be more calming than you think it is
if you allow it to exist with you.
So we're forced to exit.
Sometimes we make these big exits.
We need to make changes at these moments in our lives.
And sometimes the biggest,
best exits that we make are the ones that we never anticipated or planned for.
So how can you make the most of change and not be derailed by it?
Well,
we can keep our minds right for change and ready for change,
and you can be the boss of change if you adapt an always be changing mindset.
So how do you do that one,
disrupt your assumptions.
That's something that startups do all the time.
They don't take over industries by doing things the way it's always been done.
They're poking holes in it,
they're unlearning.
And so we spend so much time learning that sometimes we forget that unlearning
is where we actually learn the most and grow the most bucking conventional
wisdom,
for instance,
disrupting those mental models that kind of hold us hostage to operating in
particular ways.
We can also capitalize on endings.
You know,
when you're in transition,
and I know this from a lot of the work I do with both individuals and large
corporations,
when you're at a moment of of transition or you failed at something or you've
been humbled in some way,
you are so ripe for growth,
you're ready for it.
You're just soaking it all in.
So use those moments to just take it in and get to the next level in a way that
you're really almost immune to when you're floating up here thinking that
everything in life is,
is going your way.
Because what happens then is you're in a place of complacency and complacency is
a really dangerous place to operate from.
And the other thing you can do to be the boss of change is to ritualize closure.
The great mythologist Joseph Campbell,
one of my favorites,
said that we have to be willing to get rid of the life we've planned so as to
have the life that's waiting for us.
And so finding a way to re ritualized closures even when it's something that you
don't want to end,
can be really rewarding and help you to move forward.
Not to forsake the past,
but to open yourself to and guide yourself into the future.
Okay,
five
play.
This is,
you might be wondering why this one's in here.
Uh,
so we are the source of our own fulfillment,
plain and simple.
But the challenge is asking yourself,
figuring out what is it you're actually seeking,
what are you looking for?
And Are you doing the right things to allow it to find you and you defined it.
So how do we do that?
Well,
I would,
that play is one of the ways that we can do it.
Now,
clay is a tough one because you don't look,
this is a room of overachievers,
right?
You guys are gainfully employed,
everyone's intelligent.
Where does play fit into your life?
And maybe you're more enlightened than the average and you're like,
oh,
I always play every day from five to seven or whatever.
So maybe you got that part figured out.
For most of us,
we might intend to play easy to fall off of our to do list as as adults because
play is this special thing that is not part of your normal everyday life.
It's time out of time.
It's separate.
It's not about producing something that can be measured.
There's no real data around play per se.
So it can be come hard if you're scientifically oriented to justify its presence
in your life.
But really it's through play that we not only prepare for change,
but open ourselves to the possibilities that expand beyond our immediate lives.
That help us to reimagine our lives in different ways.
So instead of asking who has time for play,
ask yourself if you can afford not to play the philosopher Ludvig Vicodins Dean
said that if people did not,
sometimes you silly things,
nothing important would ever get done.
And so if you think of play no other way,
just think of it that it makes really good sense.
So how do you find your play outlets and how do you know if they're working?
Well,
I'm in a decade ago,
I joined very accidentally,
the Central Park Dance Skaters Association.
Anyone ever seen them?
Ah,
well they are a nonprofit group of really bright and amazing individuals who
skate in New York,
Central Park.
Um,
there's barricades that are set up and a with a DJ in the middle that plays old
school soul and house music and everyone is welcome to join their barricades,
but it's one of the most inclusive group you'll ever see.
Even if you can't skate,
they don't care.
They want you to join.
There's one elderly regular that goes there and he just literally bounces up and
down and people skate around him and he's a huge tourist attraction,
but the,
the,
the group is colorful as I'm painting it out to be there as lady fleet flowness
as his actual,
uh,
skate name.
We all escaped names and he comes in and is half electric,
green dragon bicycle wearing clothes.
He has embroidered with his name all over it,
peddling his latest mix CD.
Or there's the shirtless guy who,
uh,
skates with water bottles stacked on his head or the other shirtless guy who
skates backwards and just flexes his pecs.
And I've never seen either of them put their shirts on no matter how cold it
gets.
Or there's my favorites,
the Hollywood roller twins who are neither affiliated with Hollywood nor twins.
Um,
but they do have a choreographed routines that they,
that they do and they always dress alike.
And I've known them for 10 years and I still can't tell them apart.
Or the recently deceased octogenarian leader Leslie,
who only wore purple,
his house was all purple and he got married on his roller skates.
So this place,
the skate circle,
it is an adult play pen.
It is one of the happiest places you can ever walk into.
I've been sad or depressed or hung over and I've walked into the skate circle
and suddenly everything in life is perfect and great.
And I know you've felt a place like that in your life where you walk there and
nothing else matters.
So for some people it's as simple as jumping in the ocean,
but in that space,
the soulful music,
the physical flow state that you go into,
the community that's there,
it's nothing short of magical.
And I think that's,
that's the thing that's hard to capture as adults.
Magic.
It's the stuff that we believed as kids,
the magic carpets and you know,
this object would have some special powers and we kind of get it at the box
office with superhero movies and maybe star wars.
But outside of the theater it's really hard to find magic in our everyday lives.
And so in spaces like the skate circle where I don't actually know anyone's last
name,
I've had these people in my home many times,
I don't know what they do for a living when they're not skating.
And I refuse to ask them because somehow the stark realities of everyday life
seem offensive to the magic and the sacredness of that space.
So when I'm not rollerskating,
I am what you might call a karaoke enthusiast and
okay.
Do you have any karaoke lovers here?
Maybe.
All right.
Uh,
so that was not always the case.
Um,
I was shy at first and,
uh,
I would go some friends to a midtown dive bar and they would sing there duets
and that would be really jealous and wish I could sing with them.
And then one day I was like,
that's it.
I'm going to do it.
And I sang Elvira by the Oak Ridge boys.
Anyone ever heard of that song?
It was an old country western song.
That was my first 45,
and it was kinda good.
And so then I started doing a little Linda Ronstadt and some dusty Springfield
and a little Gladys knight,
and suddenly had the bug.
And so I started hosting with some friends,
some monthly Karaoke parties in Manhattan,
everywhere from Tiki bars too,
underground basement bars.
And some of them were wild and costumes,
like our pants,
optional Ballantine's Karaoke parties or the annual holiday,
Santa's Oki gathering.
But we always had the Roman cow bell and the tambourines and the taxidermy
mascots,
uh,
that would sing with people.
And it was everyone from bankers and lawyers to technologists and artists.
And it was,
again,
it was this happy place that I didn't seek out any more that I sought out the
skate circle and I didn't make a cent on this.
And it certainly did not progress my career in any meaningful way immediately.
And yet it was an important part of creating the happiness that I needed.
So our life pivots don't always come from the things that we anticipate that
they will.
Our career trajectories don't always lead from the things like the,
the degree or the promotion.
Couple of years ago I was feeling stuck professionally,
personally,
and so I decided to impose a six month limit for my unhappiness that I had to
make a move,
that I had to do something to radically shake up my life.
I explored going to Afghanistan in working as a social scientist with the troops
there.
Or the other option was I was going to move to California.
My mom was very happy that I chose the latter actually.
Uh,
but moving to California was not a choice that I made because it was so obvious
for my career and that's how I made all the other choices in my life that far.
Uh,
it was the choice that I made because I knew that's where I felt like the best
version of myself.
It's where I felt like I could actually finally flourish as a person.
And I felt that if I did that,
other things would follow.
And sure enough they did.
But the mere imaginings of allowing myself to extend beyond what felt really,
really practical suddenly opened up a world that I have you been anticipating.
I needed that giant pivot to allow myself to go beyond practicality because it's
not about practicality or passion.
Those two things are not at odds.
It's about both.
And it's about allowing play in magic in your life.
It's about giving yourself the opportunity to follow your heart,
knowing that there's also a practical application for the decisions that you're
making.
So it asks you again,
what is it that you see and are you allowing it to find you?
Do you have the permission to fantasize?
And dream in the ways that might seem silly at first,
that might seem unnecessarily playful because fantasies start to become a
reality at the intersection of your practical accomplishments and your
daydreams,
not just at the part of your career that you've planned out for the next 20
years.
So there's three simple things that I want to leave you with as you remember and
start to start up your life.
One is to return to your core startups,
push out MVPs all the time,
minimum viable products,
right?
They're lean,
they're simple,
they do something really well and they get it right and it resonates with
people.
But as we get older,
we things layer the should'ves layer,
the nice to haves layer,
and it becomes difficult to know what is really our core.
So ask yourself,
what's your mantra?
How can you slip?
How can you strip away the layers that have bogged you down and get back to
what's at the core of everything you do?
See if you can do that and then give yourself permission to let go of the other
stuff that doesn't actively contribute to that core.
The second thing is to settle for good enough.
Sometimes the practical application of,
of finding joy in the process is not really sexy.
Sometimes you have to settle for good enough so that you had the chance at
something that's really,
really great.
We are multidimensional,
imperfect creatures,
but perfectionism is paralyzing a lot of the time.
And that's where that fear comes back in.
So remember Eleanor Roosevelt's words,
you don't have to become a hero overnight.
The arc of your life is long.
Your ability to turn failures into successes is long.
The arc of your happiness is long.
And finally three to serve others is to serve yourself a useful life is a happy
life.
And all truism and ambition are not at odds with one another.
And we might not like everything that we see happening in the world around us,
but we get to design our own lives.
We get to decide what our legacy is going to be and how we touch the community
is that we are a part of.
And that's really empowering and helpful.
So at the end of each chapter in my book,
I offer what I call the lazy low down,
and essentially it's the top 10 chapter takeaways.
And so in case he dozed off at any point,
I'm going to leave you with the top 10 lazy load down from this presentation.
One personal fulfillment is created,
not inherited or earned to hap hazard search for happiness leads unpredictable
intermittent results,
not sustainable wellbeing.
Three,
hustle trumps pedigree.
It keeps you hungry,
and hunger always beats complacency.
Four,
give yourself permission to fail and you require the ability to succeed.
Five,
get barreled by fear.
Hang 10 on it's frothy swell and enjoy the ride.
Six,
embrace a life in transition because change is not coming.
It's already here.
Seven,
it's never too early or too late to reinvent yourself.
So pivot your life toward happiness.
Eight,
get serious.
Start playing nine champion.
Good enough.
So you have a chance at really great and 10 become an MVP,
returned to your core or just discover it for the first time.
Thank you for your time and attention.
And I'll open the,
you mentioned about ritualizing and things closer.
Yeah,
yeah.
What's your marathon?
Of course,
I'm going to read it.
Whether you meant which is have a ritual to Newcomb or whether we should make it
a habit of forcing ourselves trends every so often.
All of the chapters.
Ah,
yeah.
Well,
I think the original intention is to,
you know,
life doesn't always give us the neat and tidy endings that we want,
whether it's professionally or personally.
We're often left hanging a little bit,
and so you have to create your own closure.
And for a lot of us,
that gives us peace of minds if we're able to ritualize closure and it makes it
easier to move forward.
But I think to your other option,
that's also really important to know when enough is enough.
You know?
So I'm saying,
you know,
embrace risk and fear the,
no,
you're no,
you're breaking point.
No,
no.
When it's okay.
You don't have to be a hero overnight.
Thank you very much.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Thanks for coming.